- Me and Pete just hanging out.
Look at that face.
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Liam Payne and
I'm here at Buzzfeed
and I am about to meet a lot of puppies.
Look at you!
Hello!
Oh, you're lovely, aren't you?
Hello, come here you.
You're a rascal.
You're gonna be the rascal of the group
and you also want to join in.
(laughing)
This one really likes me.
I've got an attachment here.
All right then, let's do some questions.
I think I would
collaborate best with Zayne
because we do really
similar type of music.
And I would say that I
would like our music videos
to be right here with these puppies
because this is just
too much fun right now.
There's talk of maybe
doing a collaboration.
Maybe I'm gonna collaborate
with this guy right here.
But I can't tell you who it is yet
but she is an artist.
It's very open, isn't it?
Love the question bowl.
Do you wanna pick me a question?
What a question to follow
up with that question!
I would collaborate with Nicky
Minaj I think would be best.
My favorite part about
touring with the boys
was when we were younger, we used to spend
a lot of time together on the tour bus.
And when we did that first American tour,
we had a really tiny small bus
and it was just a lot of
fun and just hanging out
and it was like, I don't know.
That was the time when we got to
know each other best I
think throughout the band.
No, I'm not at all.
I think honestly he's really
really suited for the job
and I know that Harry's
really good at what he does.
And I wanted to congratulate the man.
It's a massive moment, like
being in a Christopher Nolan
action film, like how amazing, super cool.
I haven't seen it yet but
I am planning on having
a little event with my
team and some of my family
and going down and all of
us watching it together
'cause I wanna make sure
that it's in a night setting.
I wanna go, I haven't
been to the cinema in ages
and I'd like to go to the cinema.
You haven't said hello
very much, hello, hello!
The last text message I sent
was "Check the vids aha"
to one of my friends 'cause I was doing
some silly videos on Instagram.
That was long and boring and I thought
it was gonna be up right and exciting.
You make sure you just
stay there the whole time.
You're just quite chill.
What's your deal, Pete?
You're the naughty one of the bunch.
Come here, you.
Come on.
Yes I think we will reunite
at some point in the future.
I'm sure, we have to.
I mean we've got an album that
we haven't even toured yet
and I wanna write some more
songs as well with the boys.
The songwriting process
has been a lot different
'cause you have to look a lot
inside yourself for inspiration.
It was different when I
was writing for the boys
because you have to have
four people to please
so in a way, it's kinda easier as well
but it's hard because, it's very very,
it just relies on you I guess.
Which is nice and there's
some really personal songs
that I've done on that
album and there's some
that I do my other writers
'cause there are obviously
great writers in the
world and I've got to work
with some great people like
Farrell and Ryan Teller
and obviously Zedd at the
moment which has been great
so I've been really lucky with the people
I got to work with.
Yes and no.
There's loads of different
parts to the album
so I still can't believe
you're sat here all the time.
You're so tamed.
Yeah, and there's some ballads,
there's some hip hop songs,
there's some more dance music.
So I think there's a really varied mix
of different things that we have.
I don't know how I'm ever gonna separate
from you ever again; look at your eyes.
My go-to karaoke song would be
♫ I know when that hotline bling
♫ Hey, that can only mean one thing
(laughing)
There's actually a name for this
and it's a long something or other phobia
that they call it; I'm not sure.
But I'm no longer afraid of spoons.
My favorite songs.
That was quick.
I think I'd like to go in and play arenas.
I love a big stage and
I like running around.
I actually measured it one
time when we were on stage
and we used to do like
six kilometers a night
every times on, so we're
used to running around
a big stage so I don't know
how I feel going back to small.
I do like the smaller venues as well.
It's nice and intimate but I love to do
really big shows and I
want to put on a great show
for you guys with loads of
different elements in it so.
Oh, I never thought about that.
I would wake up at around nine.
Go to the gym for a little bit,
I'd sit and watch, I'd have the new series
of Peaky Blinders out
now; that'd be a good day.
I'm having to wait for ages.
I would have an in and out burger
'cause they are the
best thing known to man.
And that would be quite the perfect day.
Oh, you're back again.
Hello.
My favorite memory was when we first did
Madison Square Gardens.
We popped out the floor
and the crowd is just--
Oh.
Where are you going?
We popped out the floor and it was just
the most amazing feeling
ever knowing that we were
in Madison Square Gardens and our album,
we just broke the record
for debuting at number one
on the American charts so that was
a real fond memory of mine.
How are we doing Pete?
What's hanging?
I would say having my missus eye on me
is always a nice thing so I like to know
that she's always got her eye on me
and I've always got my
eye on her which is nice.
I would say Pete at this moment in time.
He's just fulfilling life for me.
I want to say thank you to
Buzzfeed for having me today
but I just wanted to let everybody know
that all these puppies are adoptable
from the North Shore
Animal League in America
so please, if you have a good home,
and you want a nice
lovely puppy like Pete,
go and get him.
Look at Pete.
Oh my God.
Pete man, you're killing me.